as of guys my name is the churner
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we introduced sprite chips and
we more or less talked about how they
work they're also called texture atlases
check out that video if you haven't
already the most important thing that I
want to do today is actually work out
some kind of API for our texture atlases
now this is something that I haven't
really like sat down and planned because
I figured it would be a probably a good
process to show you guys what I was
thinking and kind of just do it live
instead of just being like here we go
let's do this
but basically we're just gonna jump in
and we're gonna try and figure out a way
for ourselves to I guess define and use
sprite sheets now straight off the bat I
want to say that this is something that
at the moment the small amount of
thought that I have given it which has
been mostly during this introduction
that I'm now giving you guys I haven't
really there are a lot of ways that you
could implement this and unfortunately
it's one of those things that tends to
be according to your preference because
when you when you think about a sprite
sheet what is a sprite sheet so at the
core we have a texture and then some
kind of index into that sprite sheet
which we can use to determine the needed
or the required texture coordinates to
render something more specifically a
textured quad so basically if we break
all this down that's probably the best
thing to do in pretty much any
situations just to break everything down
to the actual data required so what is
the actual data that we need well we
need a texture that's step one and then
the second piece of data that we need is
just the texture coordinates that we're
going to put into our vertex buffer when
it's time to actually draw one of these
textured quads so texture and then
vertex texture coordinates that's it
now how we choose to calculate this and
abstract this away is again one of those
things is going to be really dependent
on the usage so how are we planning on
using this as someone who's writing the
code for this quote-unquote game that
we're making here how do we want to I
guess deal with textures that are
actually sub textures inside texture
atlases well ideally we probably still
want to deal with them as if
they were separate texture that's
probably the best way to do things so in
other words we probably when we load a
spreadsheet we probably want to define
all of the different textures and maybe
make variables out of them inside our
like layer inside our like level class
water wherever it may be so we load a
texture we define all of the different
sub textures and then when it's time for
us to render because we still will be
calling draw quad with an appropriate
texture this time maybe we can pass in
that definition of a sub texture instead
of the full texture and that way we can
still have just one actual texture
loaded in memory on the GPU ready to be
bound and then the rest is just
determining some kind of like set of
vertex texture coordinates that's
probably the way that we're going to go
but let's dive in and actually take a
look practically at what that would look
like so this is what we had last time we
had all these particles and we had these
stairs rendering just to test out
everything and make sure that it is okay
but right now you know let's think about
this where drawer in the quad we pass in
a texture what we actually probably want
to do is instead of passing in like m
sprite sheet we want to pass in maybe M
texture stairs or something like this
specifically to draw the stairs now we
know if we go back to render A to D we
know that the stairs themselves let me
find the appropriate function that the
stairs themselves here now draw a quad
function that we worked on last time are
at seven six that's like the coordinate
of the texture inside our sprite sheet
if we quickly open up our sprite sheet
and we can look at that so these stairs
over here we know are and I don't know
what visual studio is like look at this
well visual studio is like image editor
is don't think I've ever used it before
and I'm not digging this kind of green
background but anyway attempting to
explain this is a little bit hard and I
can't select anything because it moves
everything but whatever
so these stairs as we know are the
seventh sprite on the X I'm not even
sure I'm looking at the whole thing and
I go I can zoom out with controller and
the scroll wheel seventh on the x-axis
and sixth on the y-axis so that's where
it is I want to be able to make a
sub-region out of that and then all of
this calculating that we see here is
something that actually needs to be done
automatically I don't want to have to
deal with this I just want to be able to
define everything up front have it
linked to an actual
spritesheet being the actual OpenGL
texture that we want to bind and render
with and then everything else is going
to be automatically calculated for us
I think another more generic way to go
as well is to just make something that
is essentially a sub texture so instead
of texture 2d we could have sub texture
2d and that represents just one part of
an actual texture this could be
relatively easy to define because again
like a sub texture could literally just
be like a texture 2d raff like this Plus
these texture coordinates which we could
calculate upon like constructing because
another thing is doing all of this maths
every single time we draw a quad with
this image it's probably not a good way
to go I mean it's not required at all so
generally we want to avoid doing work
every frame and every cycle and every
time we call this function if we can and
I think that we can so I think I will
actually go down that route just because
I feel like it's it's generic enough
that it's gonna be totally fine and it
also kind of allows us to to not tie
ourselves directly to the concept of
sprite sheets or texture atlases because
that's something that is obviously very
specific to these types of games and I
probably don't necessarily want to stick
to that terminology so let's kind of
start writing this thing and again this
is something that I've literally just
just come up with on the spot so if we
end up doing a complete backflip then so
be it so let's go into our texture class
here this is it is one of those things
that again doesn't need to be render API
specific whatsoever so we have inside
platform OpenGL and an OpenGL texture
you know we have specific specifics to
OpenGL textures however this concept of
a sub texture doesn't need to be
specific whatsoever
now do I want to define the texture
class in this file I'm thinking probably
not the reason that I don't think I will
is because this as you can see is
specifically to do with like renderer
objects that's also why it's inside like
the renderer fold another that's like a
huge indicator of what should be here
but my point is these are literally
things that we created for the intention
of creating them using a render API and
having them as objects on our GPU
they're basically primitives that we use
for rendering so what I'll do is I'll
create a new item
and I'll make sure I'm ensure all files
mode because if I'm not then it's just
gonna create it in the root directory
with my project file which is not what I
want and I will call this sub texture
and I guess I'll call it sub texture 2d
because well that's what it is and I do
like descriptive names this is exciting
we're introducing a new class class sub
texture 2d now this is not like a
renderer primitive or anything like that
which is why like it's not gonna follow
the same pattern of having like a static
create function or anything like that
this is something that you can just you
know create normally like a normal
person
so we'll say Const ref texture 2d this
is basically what it's wrapping this is
our actual texture and this is also
something that is going to end up
storing so we'll say ref texture 2d
texture however we may actually end up
providing some kind of static creation
functions just to make this a little bit
easier so in other words we could
basically choose to create something
like as a sprite sheet and then pass in
like the size of each sprite for example
but ultimately as I mentioned before our
goal here is to have a set of texture
coordinates so I'll say text chords will
have four of them we know that we need
four of them let me just include GLM
here as well slash GLM I'll extend this
this constructor to be the most kind of
general case so in other words this is
basically going to be like the minimum
bound and then we're gonna have a
maximum bound as well let's also create
a CPP file for this sub texture or stub
texture 2d dot CPP will include our PCH
and also our sub texture 2d once I've
done that I'm just gonna go and
implement this constructor
now this is going to obviously set our
texture to be texture and then with
calculating the texture coordinates this
is really where the meat is going to
come into play again the core of this
and I'll write this out very simply is
going to be this these are supposed to
be texture coordinates that you pass in
if you want a sub texture it should be
very simple in that sense so texture
coordinates zero here are going to be
min dot X and Minn dot Y if you picture
this being like the bottom left corner
and I'm just writing them out like this
so that they match up and
easy to read then the texture
coordinates for the bottom right side
are going to be max dot X and then min
dot y then we're gonna have max X max Y
and I'm gonna have min X and Max Y so
now we have every combination of these
and these are in fact our correct
texture coordinates now this is fine and
this is really all we need we could
really provide like any mechanism we
want to retrieve these texture
coordinates we could even make render a
2d a front class however I think what
I'll do if we just go back to render it
it's always good to check your usage
obviously so what are we actually going
to need well we're going to need this
kind of pointer of texture coordinates
where we're going to want to copy from
at the appropriate index so just by
having like an index should be pretty
good I think so going back here what
I'll do is I'll just write a function
that retrieves our texture coordinates
and we'll mark them as Const here as
well okay so now we have the texture
coordinates and then I'll also of course
need to get this texture as well ok so
this is really all the sub texture class
needs to be as you can see it's really
simple that is at its core the data that
we need to turn everything into
essentially a sprite sheet and and more
importantly be able to actually access
those individual sprites however as I
mentioned it's going to be very useful
to us to be able to create these things
without having to actually specify the
texture coordinates and having to
compute them so what I'll do here is
I'll add some static functions static
graph sub texture 2d
create and these are actually going to
basically function as helper functions
for us so that we can create them as if
they were a sprite sheet so I'll do
create from coordinates so create from
coordinates or create from chords is
basically going to be what we did in the
render a 2d class which I'm just all
over the place with my code alright so
basically this right what we did here is
we created them based on a set of X&Y
coordinates that we specified here and
then the width and height of the shade
as well as each individual sprite width
and height so if we go back here all we
really need here is the X and the y
coordinate as well as the sprite
width and the sprite high so if we have
these two pieces of information and in
fact I think what I'll probably do is
end up converting them into vectors here
vector
right sighs and then I'll implement the
function of course and then what this is
going to do is attempt to create these
min and Max variables that we need here
using this information so let's go back
to render A to D so that I don't have to
copy too much code here I'll just copy
all of this I think and delete all the
stuff that I don't need such as this
stuff
all right so min and Max let's work them
out the coordinates x and y has become
the coordinates sheet width and sheet
height is also just the textures width
and height actually one thing I forgot
that's kind of important is to pass in
this texture now do I want to do it at
the start or at the end I think I'll do
it at the start just because it is like
the most important thing let's add this
here okay so remember we really only
need two of these because everything
else will just calculate using this so
this here is the bottom left corner and
then we have the top right corner these
are the only ones we need so I'm just
going to delete the other two here and
then let's start with changing this so
first of all x times sprite with X's of
course going to be from our coordinate
so we'll do coordinates x times sprite
width which is going to be our sprite
sighs I think sprite size dot X and then
coming over here we have chords dot y
times sprite sized or Y sheet height is
going to be texture gets height and
sheet width of course is going to be
textured get with we can get rid of
these we obviously don't need them and
then we have the same thing over here
again chords dot X plus 1 sprite with
sheet width and then sprites height
which is sprite sized oh why why of
course is chord or Y and then sheet
height is just texture get height
alright cool so that's basically all we
need now instead of having this
consecration which obviously isn't even
a Const expression we'll get rid of it
and then really all we need to do here
is create this or F sub texture 2d will
say result equals create ref let me get
rid of that space here create ref sub
texture 2d and then we just need to pass
in the texture
as well as the min and Max so just to
make this a little bit better and a
little bit easier to read I will
actually bring it out here and I'll say
min and Max instead of you know instead
of putting it into the constructor which
I could have done as well but it's okay
I think I'll just leave it like this so
that it looks better and makes more
sense all right let's take this and this
will be our max coordinate here I think
everything's correct yeah it should be
and then we'll just pass in a min and
Max yeah all right so again this is and
we can just return this so this is just
supposed to be you know think I've got a
comma down all right so this is what we
look like this is just supposed to be a
little convenience function who
basically calculated these things for us
so that we can give it some simple data
and just create them from coordinates
instead of having to calculate the
actual the actual texture coordinates on
our own inside the sandbox class or
inside our game because we don't really
want to be doing that all right so now
we just need to go into our renderer and
actually change the function to work
with this now technically you probably
want to implement this for literally
every single function that takes in
texture at least so what I'll do is I'll
do drop quad here I probably won't do it
well I guess I should do it for
everything for completeness but what
we'll do is we'll change this to be a
sub texture 2d and we'll leave I think
we still want to tile in fact to
annotate color obviously as before I'll
include sub texture 2d
over here and let's also copy and paste
rotate a quad and we'll update this
check in and the sub texture as well so
we have quite a few new functions here
let's go ahead and implement all of them
I'll grab this in fact I think what I
might do is instead of implementing them
that way first of all I think what I
want to do is revert our our function
that we actually modified which was this
one to be what it's supposed to be so if
we go to like literally any other
function and just get the texture
coordinates that's really the only thing
we changed let's paste them back here
and I think we can obviously get rid of
this I think that's exactly what it was
so that was easy and now what I'll do is
every function that had that I'm just
going to copy and paste it now at this
point a lot of it is the same really all
we're doing is calculating texture
coordinates so you could actually bring
this out and make all of this into one
fun
call it with like the texture
coordinates and stuff like that we might
do that in the future I'm not gonna rush
in and do that right now because it's
not really necessary it is unfortunate
that we have so much duplicated code
though which is why we should probably
do it as I mentioned before but this is
this is just the way it is for now so
all of this stuff it still stays the
same really the only thing that changes
is the texture coordinates this us
trying to like find an appropriate
texture and like put it into the texture
slots all of that stuff that still stays
the same it's just that what happens is
when we actually get the texture here
this is a sub texture and I'm gonna
label it as such so that we don't
confuse it because we still need the
actual real texture to render because
sub texture is kind of just a wrapper
over it and in fact I'm just gonna call
this sub texture as well so that we
don't get confused so going back here
this is just gonna call draw quad with
sub texture which we'll call this
overload and then what this is going to
do is again these texture coordinates
instead of being taken in from somewhere
else we're going to take them in by
calling sub texture what was this sub
texture get text chords like this and
then this will just be I think it counts
pointer like this and we can access them
in exactly the same way so this code
does not change whatsoever but then
texture which we don't have now we also
need to retrieve and we can just do that
by writing Kon strap texture 2d texture
equals sub texture and get texture and
that's it and you can see everything
else will work fine so that's this done
and then now we need to do the same
thing for our rotated cause the take in
textures which are these so let's copy
and paste this and yes I am now
definitely regretting my decision to not
kind of puts into one function we might
have a little maintenance episode where
we both move this out into like another
class like this specifically this like
game that were kind of working on here
and then also we'll take that
opportunity to like you know clean up
the render of class and do all that
stuff so let me grab both of these lines
of code where are they so this this and
this if we go down here this becomes
that this is a sub texture now and I
think everything else should work fine
now obviously you know we need to test
this because I just implemented this off
the top
my head and it might be wrong but the
idea is let's test this out so the idea
is we have a sprite cheer we still load
that in normally as we always do but now
the difference is and if I go to the
main hey little header file we will add
in sub texture over here so that we can
actually use it so sub texture 2d so we
do sub texture 2d just like this and
then this will be like our stairs you
know our let's just do texture stairs
and then the way that we're going to
kind of I guess and initialize this and
use it is on attach when we create our
sprite sheet we'll just do texture
stairs equals hazel sub texture 2d
create from chords and then this will be
our sprite sheet and then the
coordinates here are going to be 7 6 now
note that you can like create half
textures and stuff like that if you
wanted to because these are floats so
that's totally permissible because the
maths didn't like make sense here even
though logically minot sprite size is
128 128 okay so that just creates that
should work right because that's the
size of these sprites and I think I
think that it should just work so let's
hit a 5 and see what happens hopefully I
haven't made any mistakes
okay so we're already not compiling
let's take a look at this we have all
these linking errors okay but yeah
that's because it's in compiled text
wasn't if the definition we've got to
delete the other one let's run this
again and there your looks like we see
the stairs again I really have no way of
knowing if that worked or not because it
looks exactly the same let's open this
again inside this wonderful image editor
that we have inside visual studio and I
unfortunately keep trying to zoom out
with control - but that just closes
everything it seems ok let's shall we go
back to well you know what we don't even
need this right ok so first of all
what's gonna happen if we go out of
bounds
if I specify an index off of this then
you know - the coordinates still work
outside of bounds it's going to either
repeat what's going to clamp it's gonna
do something so that's not gonna that
shouldn't really crash let's do what was
this bush I don't really remember okay
well let's try a new sprite how about
that let's try this kind of barrel thing
so it's clearly the third sprite from
the bottom which means it's index 2 and
then here it's 1 2 3 4 5
seven eight nine wait 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
so 8 by 2 let's try that so we should
get a barrel if we change and in fact
what I'll do is I'll run a boat that'll
be a good test
so we'll do texture stairs and the
texture barrel so 8 2 right um let's
copy this and paste is here 8 2 I think
is what my barrel was okay so we're
creating it from the spreadsheet extra
barrel and then I guess I'll just render
it
let's friend a texture barrel and we'll
render this maybe add an offset of like
1
yeah 1 should be fine because I don't
think they take up the whole space I
release the barrel looks like it's a bit
thin so we should be fine all right
there we go we have a barrel we have the
stairs but clearly rendering correctly
from our spreadsheet everything looks
good so that is our new sub texture
class and in fact one final test that I
think would be useful is if we open the
texture again let's try and render one
of these trees like this orange tree for
example because this is actually it's
not a square sprite so which one is it
so 0 1 I guess we'll have to give it the
index 1 on the y-axis and 0 1 2 so it's
1 it's 2 by 1 and then it has to be
twice the height so to do that let's go
back here let's do em texture tree and
then over here we will assign it to
let's grab that spreadsheet so what we
say true 1 is that right I always forget
these numbers 0 1 2 and yeah I care - 1
I was right and then 128 by 256 tall so
I guess in this scenario this would
refer to not necessarily the size of
each sprite but the size of this
particular sprite and obviously that
means that it's going to take up twice
the height now this is actually now that
I think about it it's probably it might
work for this scenario in fact it
probably won't work for anything and the
reason is that obviously we multiply
these coordinates
so this this kind of plus one thing this
is really what we want to change too
right because if we change the sprite
size and we multiply with that then
obviously it's still going to it's just
going to be a different kind of
coordinate we're going to be dealing
with a different offset and it's still
going to be the same because we're
specifying a minute max balance so
that's something is that we should
probably fix and the only way that we
can really fix that is probably by
providing a third parameter well we have
sprite size in fact you know what let's
set that to be one by one by default and
then we'll say Const GL m and this is
gonna kind of make it even more
confusing but we'll maybe say cell size
and cell size is gonna be kind of each
grid cell how big it's actually going to
be and then we've got sprite size as a
default parameter so let's go and copy
this we'll go back we'll have to make
sure that everything's working but
basically cell size now is going to be
what x and y is so I'm reply I'm
replacing all of the sprite sizes with
cell size and sprite size on the other
hand is what we're going to actually
increment here so the chords get
incremented by the sprite size X and the
sprite size Y and really this only
happens for the max parameter here okay
so let's go back let's change this so
the cell size is still 120 about 128 but
what we do here is we set a size of 1 by
2 instead of the default of 1 by 1 so
now I guess I'll just add in the tree
here so we'll have our tree texture and
let's draw this on the other side so
we'll do negative 1 and then that's not
my tree texture and then maybe our last
thing we need to do actually let me just
cancel that build quickly because I want
to see the wrong tree let's make the
height of it - right so it's twice as
tall obviously otherwise it's still
gonna render it on a square quad and
it'll be it'll be very squished ok so
what do we have here okay brilliant
there we go
it works so now we see this
importantly like we would have seen this
before as well we could have set it up
by just drawing two sprites on top of
each other but obviously by doing it
this way it's a single quad and we're
rendering the entire texture on it all
specifically the entire tree texture on
it we don't need to split up into two
quads because that can be a little bit
annoying to do right especially if it's
just like a little tree texture we could
even make it just so that the first quad
maybe functions as a Collider or
something like that so you can go behind
the tree like that if you're the player
there's a lot of things you could you
could do here but it's cool of course
we're rendering it as one quad here so
there you go okay so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please hit
that like button you can also help
support the series by going patron on
4/2 Cherno you'll get access to plenty
of really cool perks such as access to
the 3d development branch of hazel as
well as live streams for this month of
May I've actually have the price to get
in on the live streams that I'm doing
every single week of me developing hazel
so if you guys are interested in seeing
me actually work on hazel dev the 3d
version of hazel and all that stuff then
definitely check that out and thank you
so much for your support
we've got this sub texture 2d class now
which is pretty exciting we can actually
start putting together some kind of map
and rendering it whether that be just by
like having a file that maybe maps out
where where each tile goes we also might
do it from like a string we could even
like use a noise algorithm to generate
some noise and then assign different
types of tiles to that I don't know
we'll figure it out if you guys have
suggestions of them in the comments
below for what you want to see but this
is good I'm happy with what we've got
here we're slowly working towards
extending the hazel API through actually
making a game and I think that's
probably one of the best ways to make a
gay mention it's do you want like once
you've done the core stuff and we kind
of have done a lot of the core stuff in
hazel thus far once you've done all of
that stuff you can just like you know
sit down and actually start trying to
make a game with it and then filling in
the blanks and that's what we're doing I
think it's working really well I can't
wait to see you guys in the next episode
honestly we can keep working on this
game I will see you next time goodbye
you
[Music]